so as a CEO let me ask you a question
because leadership matters
this is a complicated question
why is Mark Zuckerberg distrusted
disliked and sometimes even hated by
many people in public
right that is a complicated question
um well the premise
I'm not sure I agree with the premise
um and I could I can expand that to
include
even a more mysterious question for me
Bill Gates
what is the Bill Gates version of the
question
do you think people hate Bill Gates
no distrust ah so uh take away one it's
it's a checklist
uh there is
I think Mark Zuckerberg's distrust is
the primary one but there's also like a
like a dislike maybe hate us to strong
award but just if you look at like
the articles that are being written and
so on
there's a dislike and it makes it's
confusing to me because it's like the
public picks certain individuals and
they
and they attach certain kinds of
emotions to those individuals yeah so
someone once uh just recently said
there's a strong case that founder-led
companies have this problem and that a
lot of Marx issues
um come today come from the fact that he
is a visible founder with this story
that people have watched in both a movie
and they followed along and he's this
boy wonder kid who became one of the
world's richest people and and he's no
longer Mark the person he's marked this
this image of of a person with enormous
wealth and power and in today's world we
we have issues with enormous wealth and
power for a variety of reasons one of
which is we've been stuck inside
you know for a year and a half two years
uh one of which is a lot of people were
really unhappy about not the last
election but the last last election and
where do you take out that anger who do
you blame but the people in charge
that's one example or one reason why I
think
um a lot of people
uh Express anger or resentment or
unhappiness with
with Mark at the same time
I don't know I pointed out to that
person I was like well I don't know like
I think a lot of people really like Elon
like
Elana arguably like he kept his you know
Factory open here throughout coveted
protocols which arguably a lot of people
would be against
um while saying a bunch of uh crazy
offensive things on the internet they
still like basically you know
gives the middle finger to the SEC like
on Twitter and like I don't know I'm
like well there's a founder and like
people kind of like him so I do think
that
the so like the the founder and slash
CEO of a company that's a social network
company is like an extra level of
difficulty if if life is a video game
you just chose the harder of it you get
so I mean that's why it's interesting to
ask you because you were the founder and
CEO yes of a social network right I
challenge it because exactly so but but
you're one of the rare
examples even Jack dorsey's disliked
not to the degree but it just seems
harder when you're running a social
media company it's interesting I I never
thought of Jack as just like I think
generally he's well respected
um yeah I think so I I think you're
right but like he's but he's not loved
yeah and I feel like you I mean to me
Twitter is an incredible thing yeah
again can I just come back to this point
which seems over simplistic but like I
really do think how a product makes
someone feel yeah they ascribe that
feeling to the founder yep uh
so so make people feel good so think
about it like let's just go with this
thesis first actually sure I like it
though um Amazon's pretty utilitarian
right it delivers Brown boxes to your
front door sure you can have Alexa and
you can have all these things right but
in general it delivers stuff quickly to
you at a reasonable price right
I think Jeff Bezos is wonderfully
wealthy thoughtful smart guy right but
like people kind of feel that way about
them they're like wow this is really big
we're impressed that this is really big
and but they he's doing the same space
stuff elon's doing but they don't
necessarily ascribe the same sense of
wonder right
um now let's take Elon uh and again this
is pet Theory I don't have much proof
other than my own intuition
um he is literally about living the
future
Mars space it's about Wonder it's about
going back to that feeling as a kid when
you looked up to the stars and asked is
there life out there
people get behind that because it's a
sense of hope and excitement and and
Innovation and like you can say whatever
you want but we we ascribe that emotion
to that person now let's say you're on a
social network and people make you kind
of angry because they disagree with you
or they say something ridiculous or
they're living a fomo type life where
you're like wow I wish I was doing that
thing
I think Instagram if I were to think
back by and large when I was there was
not about fomo was not about this
influence or economy although it
certainly became that way closer to the
end
it was about the sense of wonder and
happiness and beautiful things in the
world and
I don't know I mean like I don't want to
have a blind spot but I don't think
anyone had a strong opinion about it for
the longest time the way people explain
to me I mean if you want to go for
toxicity you go to Facebook or Twitter
if you want to go to make feel good
about life you go to Instagram to enjoy
Celebrate life though in my experience
been talking to people is they gave me
the benefit of the doubt because of that
but if your experience of the product is
kind of makes you angry it's where you
argue
I mean a big part of Jack might be that
he wasn't actually the CEO for a very
long time and only became recently so
I'm not sure how much of the connection
got made
um but in general I mean if you hate you
know
I'm just thinking about other companies
that are on tech companies if you hate
like what a company is doing or it makes
you not feel happy
I don't know like people are really
angry about Comcast or whatever are they
even called Comcast anymore it's like
Xfinity or something right they had to
Rebrand they they became meta right
um it's like uh but my point is if it
makes you beautiful yeah but the thing
is
foreign
this is me saying this I think your
thesis is very strong and correct has
elements of correctness but I still
personally
put some blame on individuals of course
I think uh you said Elon looking up
there's something about childlike wander
to him like to his personality his
character
something about I think more so than
others what people can trust them and
there's uh I don't know Senator is an
example of somebody who's like there's
some kind it's it's hard to put into
words but there's something about the
human being where he's trustworthy yeah
his human in a way that uh connects to
us and the same with uh Sergeant Nadella
I mean some of these folks
um something about us is drawn to them
even when they're flawed even like um so
like your thesis really holds up for
Steve Jobs because I think people didn't
like Steve Jobs but like he delivered
products that and then they fell in love
every time
uh I guess you could say that the CEO
the leader is also a product
and if they keep delivering a product
that people like by being in public and
saying things that people like that's
also a way to make people happy